thank you so yeah so we're not going to
apply invariance here but there's going
to be variance so we're going to switch
to another topic so proof complexity
lower bounds from graph expansion and
since it's you know getting late in the
day we'll try to relax a bit and play
cognate oriole games and this is joint
work with with modern mixture and
malaria so proof complexity in one
sentence we want to certify the
unsatisfiability of CNF formulas or
rather we want to prove that it's hard
to certify this and a general theme if
you look at many lower bounds or that
somehow you look at the CNF formula that
you want to prove a lower bound for you
say that it's expanding in some way and
then you argue from expansion that it
means that it will be hard to refute
this formula and we know how to do this
for resolution and for polynomial
calculus and I'll tell you in a moment
what these proof systems are polynomial
calculus are kind of the excusive is the
excuse for giving this talk in this
workshop but somewhat annoyingly what
expanding means tends to be like
formulas specific some kind of hack it's
very similar
somehow in spirit for different formulas
but still different so what we wanted to
do we wanted to take a step back and try
to abstract away what's going on and and
somehow try to do proof complexity lower
bounds actually without knowing any
proof complexity so that's the plan
today when you're leaving this talk
you'll know how to prove you know lower
bounds for resolution and polynomial
calculus you'll be totally on top of
everything and you don't even need to
know proof complexity so that's the plan
so what are we going to do well sort of
what most of these proofs do actually
you look at the CNF formula suppose we
have this CNF formula here so we somehow
look at it then we'll analyze the
structure and then we'll build a
bipartite graph from it so somehow you
know these clauses will go together in a
vertex this will go together in a vertex
and here we have another vertex and then
we look at the variables and we somehow
divide them up also it doesn't have to
be partition though as you see how Y
appears several times W appears several
times but for some reason we're you know
dividing them up into this way and once
we've done this division the it's clear
what the graph will be because we'll
have an edge if some variable over here
appears in some clothes over here
so for instance W appears here so we
have an edge X appears here so we have
an edge W appears there also so the
graph doesn't it's kind of a boring job
here but you know this doesn't always
happen good so and now we want to prove
a lower bound if two things hold so we
want to argue that the graph has to be a
very good expander so that's you know
looking promising so far and if we also
can win a certain combinatorial game on
every edge of this graph so the game is
going to be as follows so we need to be
able to win the game yes so are you
saying that if there exists right-hand
vertices such that this is an expander
you can win the game
good point Thanks so we're going to look
at the graph if we were going to look at
the CNF form we are free to you know
build the vertices as we like we're free
to partition the variables as we like
once we've decided on these vertices the
graph is sort of gives itself and now we
want to argue we need expansion and we
need to be able to win the game okay so
the game is going to be suppose we're
going to play on this edge yeah if I can
if I can do these two things like if the
graph is an expander if I can win the
game then I get a lower ball I'll make
all this precise later so but just to
give you sort of a sense of what's going
to happen so the adversary is going to
assign all variables suppose we're
playing on this edge so the adversary is
going to assign all variables
then we're out to flip these variables
if we like and then when the dust
settles all of these closes should be
satisfied if so we want again yeah and
we should be able to win this game on
every edge await the adversity of
science then we pick the edge or know
the game is after the edges chosen you
were going to play this on every edge so
you could think of the adversary
choosing the edge but the assignment is
chosen before the edge know they had
this fixed first
the edge is fixed first and yeah so you
know that you you should be able to play
this on every edge and again the
adversary assigns all other variables we
assign the variables on the right for
this particular vertex and then we win
if all the clauses on the left hand side
of truth except I didn't specify the
protocol fully like who goes first is it
we or the adversary and the sort of
conceptual message of this talk is well
it depends on which true system you're
interested in if you're happy with
resolution lower bounds then the
adversary goes first and then we can
respond however if you want polynomial
capitalist lower bounds it's a stronger
proof system then you need to play more
challenging game then we go first and
the adversary responds it's still the
case that we get to decide these
variables but we have to announce to the
adversary first how we're going to set
them and then the others are available
so it's clearly a harder game to play
closest to is right on the right yes in
this particular now only only in here
okay I don't I don't care about if we're
playing on this edge only these right
you can't have a fully satisfying assign
because this will be like an unsatisfied
will CNF formula so that would be a hard
game to it
every what X on the right hand side let
me get to it in like you know a few
minutes from now this is sort of just
our sort of you know prepare you for
what so what's the so this is actually
just building on two very influential
papers by Ben so Simon Peter song and
Alec Norwich and Roseboro and it sort of
provides a unified way of presenting
most proof context the proof complex the
lower ones for resolution of polynomial
calculus and thanks to this nice simple
framework you can also get a bunch of
new ones that I hope to get to towards
the end of the talk so what the plan is
now I'll start with a kind of a survey
ish part where I tell you what
resolution is for polynomial calculus is
okay and then I'll answer all your
questions about what this game actually
is and tell you how to prove lower
bounds and then some some results that
follow from this and some open problems
that's the and okay so we're going to
talk about you know it's getting late in
the day CNF formulas
connections of clauses every clause is a
disjunction of literals bar denotes
negation and often you know when I talk
about K CNF formulas the assumption is
that case some small fixed concept okay
resolution so you start with the clauses
of the CNF formula you can apply the
resolution rule to derive new clauses
until you reach contradiction and again
since it is late in the day let's do a
small example to make sure we're all on
the same page here is the CNF formula
consisting of five clauses I claim that
it's unsatisfiable I can represent this
refutation in two ways as an annotated
list here's the list where I'm
explaining so the input I will call them
axioms and then I explain you know if I
take clauses two and four and resolve
them over zebb using the resolution rule
then I derive X or not Y okay and then I
take this new clause and resolve it with
the first clause over Y and I derive X
so this means so far I proven to you
that any satisfying assignment to this
formula has to set X to true right but
now let me combine closest three and
five resolve over is N and I've derive
now not X so this
clearly a contradiction and the final
formal step is to just resolve these two
clauses to derive the empty clause
contradiction okay and I can also
represent this proof ease I like as a
dag where I show how the derivations
were made and in this particular case it
happens that it's a tree and I say it's
a tree like resolution proof so the most
important proof complexity measure that
we care about for resolution of Aranea
the proof system is size which for
resolution we can just count the number
of clauses it's never worse than
exponential in the number of variables
and there are matching lower bounds in
fact not only in the number of variables
are slightly stronger even in formula
size another measure that we're going to
care about is width which is the size of
a largest clause in the refutation and
it will be clear in a little bit why
this is a helpful measure to look at and
just to see here that the length of this
is one two three four five six seven
eight nine and this is the widest claw
so the width is three
so but let's move on to a more
functional system that is polynomial
calculus so now we interpret clauses as
multi linear polynomials over some field
your favorite field and so X or Y or not
Z gets translated to X bar times y bar
times Z you're sort of looking at you
know if this clause is supposed to be
false then not X not Y & Z all have to
be true that so we should think about it
yes so this is formally there are bar
variables and there are non bar
variables they're formally distinct okay
and we have a particular axiom that
tells us what the meaning of negation is
so these are X and X bar or formally
distinct variables but they're negated
they're related by this polynomial that
is an axiom I also have x squared minus
X or alternatively I could just work in
the ring where I mode out by all of
these guys and I only work with multi
linear polynomials and then I can take
linear combinations I can multiply by
variable and my goal is to derive one
which is possible if and only if the
formulas on satisfiable and this is just
formalizing what you know with revenue
bases computation
and now if I set it up in this way yeah
complexity measures size and degree so
every class turns into a monomial so in
resolution we're accounting clauses now
we'll count monomials and will write the
polynomials will insist on a very
specific stupid polynomial
representation namely as linear
combinations and mono means that's so
the size is going to be the total number
of monomials that you see in a proof and
degree is the largest degree of any
monomial and you see that Clause width
will turn into monomial degree so size
and degree and it's not so hard to see
that polynomial calculus is at least as
strong as a resolution because you can
simulate the resolution refutation line
by line so if you look at the first
resolution step we did we resolve these
two clauses X or not Y or is that and
not Y or not said and the right Dijkstra
not Y this is how I will do it in in
polynomial calculus first I just take
these two clauses and I've sort of
weakened them to speak about the same
variables so I multiply by that here and
then I just use the fact that I have
this semantics for the Z variable and I
multiplied by all the other variables
and I'm then I just add up and boom
here's the clause I wanted to derive
damn you know maybe you don't see this
totally online but offline with pen and
paper in just a minute you'll figure
that this always works good so let me
tell you some of what we know some
classic results for these proof systems
random k CNF formula is my first example
so if you just sample Delta n K clauses
over n variables so for 3-cnf without
4.5 is enough then asymptotically almost
surely you'd get an unsatisfiable CNF
formula and this is exponentially hard
both for polynomial captures
slightly more interesting example or
pigeonhole principle formulas very
heavily studied improve complexity so
encoding that n plus 1 pigeons don't fit
into n holes except we want an
unsatisfiable CNF formula so of course
our C and F will say that this is
completely possible every pigeon is
getting a hole for every hole J it is
the case that no two pigeons i and i
prime go into that hole then there I can
vary things a bit I can also say oh this
is actually a mapping you know every
pigeon gets exactly one hole and then if
I have a you know heightened sense of
fairness I say well you know then every
hole should also get a pigeon I have a
perfect matching resolution doesn't
really care I mean all of these versions
of the pigeonhole principle like dead
hard for resolution for polynomial
calculus it's it's more interesting so
the vanilla version consisting of this
this two type of clauses is
exponentially hard if you actually say
that you have an on to functional
pigeonhole principle so perfect matching
then it's actually easy it's not so hard
to see over any field and for for the
versions in between if you just have
functionality axioms or just onto axioms
actually you hasn't been known and the
third so and this in particular this
shows also that because of the on to
functional pigeonhole principle this
shows the polynomial calculus is
strictly more powerful than resolution
another interesting class of formulas
are encoding the handshaking lemma or
that the sums of degrees of vertices in
an undirected graph is an even number
okay so we encode this in a sneaky way
by labeling vertices 0 1 in such a way
that their sum is an odd numbered edges
will be the variable and every vertex
now has a constraint saying that the
parity of the truth values of my edges
incident to me is equal to my label so
this vertex wants x and y to have odd
parity these are these two clauses and
this vertex wants y&z to have even
parity and that's these two clauses and
if you plug in an expander graph there's
a six
honestly hard for resolution for
polynomial calculus if we're not over a
field of characteristic two but if you
are over GF 2 then just do Gaussian
elimination in CC so the field can
matter a lot okay so that's like some of
the classic results okay so how do you
prove lower bounds well turns out that
with an degree are very helpful measures
to look at so one easy thing is to say
well if I have an upper bound on with
their degree say W then it gives an
upper bound of size that is essentially
n to the W and this is tight in the
worst case what is not so obvious is
that if you have a strong enough width
or degree lower bound then that gives me
a size lower bound so here's the formal
statement by so this is by rustling
pallazzo popular potluck in ug scout for
polynomial calculus and then for benzos
on from vessels on a meter song for for
resolution so if I can prove so I if I
have a width or degree lower on W then
the size is exponential in W squared
divided by the number of variables so
what this means is that if I can prove a
lower bound that is growing
asymptotically faster than square root n
log n then I have a super polynomial
lower bound if I can get a linear degree
or size lower bound and I have a truly
exponential size lower bound and this is
also tight we know that there are no
implications for if you actually just
reach square root n then you can still
be very easy
and now this is like a key theorem you
can use it to prove most resolution
lower bounds in the literature there's a
well-developed machinery to prove with
lower bounds and we also have lots of
other tools for resolution for
polynomial calculus there are two
problems firstly it's way harder to
prove degree lower bounds we're not very
good at it and secondly this is sort of
the only game in town we don't have good
other good tool this is is there are
lots of nice open problems there and so
ok so now I'm going to tell you soon
about how to prove the lower bounds
except if you were paying attention
there's a problem if you want to use
this to prove pigeonhole principle lower
bounds because the proof width is
obviously very large here because you
know the initial clauses are very large
so what do we do for the pigeonhole
principle we hit the formula with a
random restriction so we just restrict
pigeons so that they can only go to see
a constant number of neighbors randomly
chosen and then you get a grasp
pigeonhole principle and you have them
in all flavors vanilla on to functional
etc and now if I can prove a strong with
lower bound for these formulas then that
gives me strong sized lower bounds for
these formulas which must obviously hold
also for the unrestricted formulas plus
we sort of obsessed sin proof complexity
about the pigeonhole principle formula
so we're also very interested in graph
pigeonhole principle for principle so
you are trying to give a different so
for Peter for polynomial calculus we
don't know it if you throw in
functionality axioms or onto axioms we
only have it for the vanilla version
we're only pigeons get holes and holes
get pigeons but as soon as I say that
every pigeons get exactly one hold in
the lower bound breaks
- how does vixx define so I mean I
forget to the there are large axioms
versus large the right classes are you
differentiating we know that the width
is just the largest clause that you have
in the proof so if there are large
initial closes you have to deal with
them some way because they're going to
mess things up for you holds but it's
sort of oh right yeah yeah yeah this as
I say that it it's only for case units
yes thanks
yeah so I was sort of assuming in the
statement that yeah well there was a
cater and that's sort of I said at the
beginning that this was supposed to be a
constant I could have said it again okay
yeah there is a general what will happen
is the initial degree will be subtracted
from this okay
so then you did so the statement is
still true but you have to subtract the
degree there and then it will be no fun
you won't get anything okay so how do
you prove lower bounds well the width
okay good how do you prove with low runs
from expansion so here's a simple
example you just take the CNF formula
and you look at the closed variable
incidence graph every Clause gets a
vertex every variable get a vertex every
edge is just that a variable occurs okay
and now we're going to look at expansion
and particular we're going to look at
boundary expansion or unique
neighborhood function so that means that
you look at a set of clauses you look at
their neighbors and you look at the
neighbors that are unique neighbors that
are in the boundaries so these three
guys we're only interested in them yeah
which means that actually if you look at
complete graphs will be bad for us
because the unique expansion is like
non-existent
the problem and this this works great
but the problem is that if you start
thinking about pigeonhole principle
formulas or sating form as for instance
suppose you have like it's taking
formula which encodes parity constraints
well you know they're going to be many
clauses to encode each parity constraint
and this is not going to be an expander
at all okay so we want to build another
graph that somehow captures the
combinatorial structure so this is what
we're going to do so we're going to do
this basically guided by our
understanding of the formula we
partition the variables into clauses and
then actually we're going to add
something down here at the bottom a
special claw set and I'll call e that
will not take part in the graph and then
I'll somehow divide the variables and
I'll keep track of the overlap how many
times the variable appears over here and
I want that to be some constant here the
overlap is to I want to be bounded and
then I build that the bipartite graph
that I just told you before and the role
of this e set is basically just it's
going to decide which kind of
truth-value assignments were interested
in and for those of you who know for
pigeonhole principles you could you
should think about the e set making sure
that we only consider partial matching
for instance and then so we're going to
play this combinatorial game so here it
is exactly specified so the adversary
chooses a total assignment so the edge
is pre specified so the edge is fixed
first we know which edge we're playing
on the adversary shoes is a total
assignment but it has to satisfy the
filter set it has to be like a valid
assignment okay we get to modify it on
the variables in the right hand side
vertex okay and then we win if our
assignment is also valid it's satisfied
the filter and it satisfies the clauses
we were playing okay so now let's play
this game
this is hopefully exactly the same as
this okay so let's play on this edge so
can we win no we can't win because
suppose the adversary plays X is true
and all other variables are false then
this clause is false and we can't do
anything about this because you know we
can't even flip those variables so this
is you should not build your graph in
this way okay so a more interesting
example let's play on this edge can we
win
yeah the answer is no the adversary
again plays W Y and said false and X we
don't really care and let us see why so
I have to satisfy the filter and I can
only flip Y which means that I can't
flick Y because then I'm screwing up
okay and I can't flip that because it's
not in v2 but if you now look at f1 it
means that I would have to satisfy both
X and not X and I can't flip X to do
that so we're losing on this edge so
what about this edge so here things are
better because the adversary goes first
and then whatever the adversary does we
just set X to be the or of y&z so we're
not touching Y or or Zed so clearly
we're not violating the filter and if
you look at what I have to said it's
just the encoding that X is the world
so if you want to do resolution lower
bounds you want that all edges should be
of this type ok is this okay
so again the boundary of a set is just
the unique neighbors on the right and
now there let's say that a resolution
expander is a graph that has good
boundary expansion and I can win this
game on every edge okay then the claim
is that if I have a CNF formula and if
from it I can build an expander graph
such that all sets of size at most s
expand by a factor Delta and I can win
the resolution game with edge width with
the filters at E and the overlap is at
most L which you should think of as a
constant then yeah so they all will
appear with two against so think of it
as a constant then the interesting thing
is like the interesting term here is
Delta s which will be this will be a
positive constant this will be linear so
now I get a like a linear with lower
ball and this is essentially pencil from
a bigger zone
okay I sort of have it again okay but
they don't express it this way so let me
actually just to give you one or one and
a half technical slide let me sketch to
you sort of how the proof would go and
you'll be able to fill in the details of
line so suppose that we have a
resolution derivation starting from this
formula and every clause has way that
mostest okay then
I'll define some kind of subsets of
clauses in my formula I'll call it the
support and I'll prove two things that
the support is fairly small and that the
support of a clause together with this
filter set actually implies the close
now I'm going to prove that on the next
slide if I can do this then since the
support is so small then actually the
support Union the filter said it is
satisfiable set okay but if it is
satisfiable and implies see then that
means that C is also satisfiable so it's
not contradiction so we didn't derive
contradiction in this small width QED
okay so what's the support going to be
well the support is going to be I'm
going to somehow throw in a new Clause
down here and I'm going to look at if
this would have been a vertex you know
what neighbors wouldn't have had maybe
these two and then the support is going
to be all of the vertices in here sort
of such that the unique neighbors of the
set land inside the neighbourhood of
this clause
so I'm going to find the support of a
clause as the largest set that is of
size at most s and such that the unique
neighbors are all contained in the
vertices of variables that the clause
also mentions and now I just have to
prove three things that this is well
defined because that is not at all clear
but it is by expansion then I have to
prove that to support this small that's
also true by expansion and then I have
to prove this implication and this is
where the edge game comes into okay and
this is sort of going fast and it's
getting late but really this is all
there is to it if you just take these
definitions you would be able to figure
this out and so I won't have time we'll
do something very similar so jumping
ahead a bit we'll do something very
similar for polynomial calculus the
definitions will be the same the proof
will sort of somehow be the same except
that it gets way more messy and I don't
have time to say anything about it okay
so but once I have this so now you know
if you're going to in your computational
complexity course you're going to give
this one lecture on on proof completely
now you can do all the proof complexity
level it's 18 the left-hand vertices are
going to be the parity constraints so
all clauses encoding one particle
strength course is the one bag the
variable vertices are going to be single
tones there is no filter we're
interested in all assignments and you
just look at the graph and if the
underlying graph is an expander is an
edge expander then your graph that
you're building will be an expander with
the same parameters and the lower bound
follows and for the pigeonhole principle
formulas the left-hand side are just
going to be the pigeon axioms like every
axiom saying that a pigeon gets a hole
is its own vertex the variable bags are
going to be talking about holes so every
variable mentioning hole J goes into the
J bag and then will have all hole
functional and on two axioms they go
into the filter so that we want to
actually
consider maximal matchings and then
again if you look at the graph version
you basically this just gives you back
exactly the same graph as you had so if
the original graph was an expander then
this graph is an expander and you have a
load yeah the games are like yeah
because in the taking for that we're
going to play okay good good in that
settings formula the adversary says I
want you to satisfy this parity okay and
you said fine you know how do you set
all other variables and then you decide
whether you want to flip a variable in
the party or not okay and for the
pigeonhole principle you say okay good
give me a partial matching and if the
pigeon we're playing on is not satisfied
then I just make sure that no other
pigeon goes into that hole but my pigeon
goes into that hole note that that can
make other pigeons very unhappy but I
don't care about other pinions I just
care about the pigeon we're playing on
does that make okay so this gives us
resolution with lower bounds but it
couldn't give us polynomial calculus
lower bounds because both say teen and
on to functional pigeon on principle are
easy for polynomials so something has to
change and what's going to change is
we're going to switch the order of the
players so we're still going to play on
an edge FV but we have to go first and
say how we want to set the variables in
V and then the adversary sets the other
variables and now it becomes very hard
to win on Satan right because we have a
parity of several variables and I set
the first and then the adversary says
okay I see and sets the rest so that the
parity is false so now we can
so what we need to do is when we're
playing on a variable bag we somehow
need to make sure that we set all
clauses in F to true and we also have to
if we're touching a clause in the filter
set then we have to satisfy it it's okay
to just miss clauses and the filtering
set but if we're touching it we have to
satisfy okay so here is our example
graph again so remember that we lost in
the read the resolution game is a is an
easier game so if you're losing already
there than we're screwed so we lost on
this edge we lost on this edge we won on
this edge in the resolution game so now
let's see what happens if we want to
play the PC educate the polynomial
calculus edge game so now we actually
lose because if you think about it so
we're going to touch the filter set so
we have to set Y to false okay and then
we have to set X but X was encoding that
Y or Z it was true but we don't have
control over Z so of course you know
basically this is saying that X N and Z
have to have the same value but we don't
have control over set so the adversary
will just play the opposite value and we
go first so now we'll use suppose we
play on this edge well then we can win
and this is sort of a small trivial
example but let's see why we set X to
true and Y to false so now we satisfy
because X is true and Y is false that
satisfies all the clauses is in F 3 and
we're also satisfying the filter yes
very good point this is a this will only
work for lower bounds that are true over
any field yes yes you're like you're
like 9 slides ahead of me but you're
absolutely right yeah
okay so now we just have the same
instead of a resolution expander let's
talk about the polynomial calculus
expander if it is a boundary expander
and if one every edge we can win the
edge game and then we get exactly the
same statement that the degree is now
Delta s so the expansion factor times
the size we can guarantee for the
expansion divided by the Overland which
will keep to something called this I
will again sort of the definitions I
gave for resolution are actually very
similar to what we'll do here but the
technical details will have to look at
different polynomial ideas and reduce
modulo them and then grow and shrink
these ideals and have control over what
happens an expansion is going to be very
important okay so do we have time for
okay so what happens so this is a way of
basically giving all lower bounds for
polynomial calculus except the ones that
depend on the characteristic and we can
do some new lower bounds that I hope to
be able to tell you about the fractional
pigeonhole principle and also for graph
coloring functional the pigeonhole
principle what's known so I said for
resolution
Hakan prove that the vanilla version is
hard but his proof actually extends to
all versions for polynomial calculus
I'll acknowledge Roseboro proved that
the vanilla version is hard Riis
observed that the on to fractional
pigeonhole principle is easy and in
between it hasn't been clear okay but so
what we did is we observed firstly that
actually I left no which has bore up
dead take care of the onto version also
but they just didn't say it or observe
it and for the function of pigeonhole
principle it turns out it is hard and
how we're going to prove it is we're
just going to build a graph and it's
essentially going to be the same graph
as before except on the right we're
going to have not holes but we're going
to like in VJ whoops that was not
intentional
we're going to have all variables
speaking about like we fix a whole J we
look at all pigeons that can go into
that hole and all other holds they could
go to and all of those variables will
somehow be related to the right-hand
vertex J and now once we have this and
once we have this PCE expander game it's
just something that you easily verify
with pen and paper now we've done we
have a load taking the complete pigeon
hole graph and then taking a random sub
graph of that is it
yeah but this is like something slightly
stronger I mean it you can just as long
as you do it adversely as long as you
guarantee me that you have a certain
expansion that we get a little more but
in particular if you want it only for
the complete graph then you'll take a
random restriction and that will give
you an expander yeah or there is a way
to restrict it to another formula that
is interesting is graph coloring stating
that a graph is K colorable so for
resolution we've actually had average
case lower bounds for erdos-renyi graphs
with the right edge density this is by
cold beam and others for polynomial
calculus nothing has been known very
annoying me no lower one whatsoever and
in particular it turns out that there is
a line of work that proves that there
are algorithms based on not polynomial
characters but new standards up that
works really well in practice and solves
coloring for graphs with thousands of
vertices and they write in this paper
this is like an award winning sequence
of papers in the art community and they
write we cannot find hard instances for
this I mean they know what NP is they
know that they probably didn't Solon and
P complete problem but they're
explicitly asking for like show us a
hard instance instance what we're going
to do is we're going to use the fact
that we now know that functional
pigeonhole principle is hard and we're
going to reduce functional pigeon on
principle instances to coloring and
we're going to show that somehow
polynomial calculus is strong enough to
compete
this reduction and we're running out of
time I guess home okay that's plenty
so I'll just sort of give you some
high-level pictures how these goes and I
should say that we use like a zero one
encoding for these variables so these
variables will just be set to 0 1 and
you have axioms saying that for so X V I
is just which color I the variable V
gets and then you make sure that every
vertex gets just the same color the
papers over in the or community use a
slightly different case root of unity
encoding but you can take our proof and
make it work for their encoding also so
good so we have a functional pigeonhole
principle instance on an expander graph
with left degree K where K is like the
number of colors and so for every pigeon
I we have a bunch we have K available
holes and we're going to think about
every pigeon as being a vertex and we
color it by the edge it chooses and now
if if pigeon
if pigeon I cannot take edge C and P
turn I prime cannot take edge C prime
simultaneously because they would end up
in the same hole then we think of this
as okay you can't color i by c and i
prime by C prime simultaneously so this
is kind of coloring but it's not
coloring but it color its coloring ish
and well what we'll do is just will will
bend the gadget to make it into coloring
so here's the gadget for for coloring so
these are going to be pre colored
vertices that will take care of later
and this is just saying that if pigeon I
and i prime both take the green edge
then they collide okay so any coloring
for these pigeons are going to be okay
except the green green coloring and to
see why is suppose that pit and i takes
the green color then we have to use up
all other colors for the clique and so
the rightmost vertex in the gadget has
to be green and now you have exactly the
same situation on the on the right where
the leftmost vertex in the gadget has to
be green right
any other coloring will be okay and if
you wanted the colors to be different
than you just identified it two vertices
in space good
so that's coloring global but worst case
only but you know it's at least an
exponential lower bound for graph color
okay so grab nerd base is provably don't
solve np-complete problems great some
open problems through lower bounds for
for instance independent set for graph
coloring in average case there's a what
seems to be a slightly easier problem
so-called dense linear ordering formulas
that we don't know how to prove degree
lower bounds for you know it'd be very
happy to talk to you about it for
resolution we have many other tools for
polynomial chapters this is not the case
so for instance we it's still consistent
with state of the art and maybe grammar
basis actually solves the K clique
problem efficiently we also don't know
what happens when you blow up the number
of pigeons to be N squared or above
because then the degree lower bound
doesn't give us anything that's another
great problem and as Russell noted so
our technique only works independently
of the field and if now it's Russ Borov
has actually another version of the
technique that can deal with different
characteristics it would be great if we
could somehow merge these two because
that would allow us to prove some lower
bells that we don't know how to do today
so you know it's we're at the end of the
day thanks for sticking around so long
so what I tried to present to you was a
unified framework for most proof
complexity lower bounds for a solution
and polynomial calculus and I think
what's nice it's sort of it's exactly
the same framework the only difference
is who goes first in this game which i
think is nice and then this gives us
lower bounds for functional pigeonhole
principle and for graph coloring we'd
like to extend these techniques to work
for other tricky formulas and to find
other tools than degree lower bounds for
polynomial counts
[Applause]
[Applause]